Our mitochondria-enhancine supplements, such as urocytid a safe for use during cancer.
The standard answer, a lot of functional medicine doctors out there, okay so how can I
say this to not be offensive?
We have a lot of people that come to us that we're put on supplements that I don't, I personally
wouldn't recommend for somebody with cancer and here's the reason.
A cancer is rapidly replicated by definition, so something got inside of a cell and damaged
the nucleus, many times it's an oxidative agent, many times it's some sort of toxin, a poison
can be a biotoxin, but it damaged the nucleus and now that cell is rapidly replicated, cells
that are also damaged in rapid replication.
By that definition, they are not replicating super-healthy cells, so the mitochondria of
these new rapidly replicated cells is not producing the right type of antioxidants in the right
quantity of antioxidants to keep that cell healthy, so they're not producing a lot of
antioxidants.
I know they're not producing a lot of super-oxide, this retains some catalysts.
That makes a cancer cell closer to legal dose of oxidative stress building up within the
cell and we take advantage of that, so knowing that a cancer cell is less healthy than a healthy
cell because it has a greater amount of oxidative stress building up within the cell because the
mitochondria are less healthy.
We can take advantage of that, and medicine takes advantage of that, that's what chemotherapy
does, chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent, and in doing so it tips over cancer cells faster
that it will tip over a healthy cell that's got a healthy mitochondria and is producing
a lot of antioxidants.
So would we go and take exogenous antioxidants, we need supplements of antioxidants, we take
supplements that are going to support mitochondrial function, we take glutathione, we take super-oxide
dispatation catalysts, and other antioxidants, then we are basically helping cancer cells stay
alive.
So I don't think that's a good idea, most natural cancer treatments, okay, standards of care
cancer treatments, chemotherapy are oxidizing agents, they're trying to tip over cells that are
already in oxidative stress, most alternative cancer therapies, proto-cell and IV, IV vitamin C,
and dematine and oxy and things like that are also oxidative, so they're tipping over those cells,
maybe less damaging way to healthy cells, and that's the argument for alternative care,
but if you are also taking a bunch of antioxidants, because you know they're good for you,
by that's your graph, what we have these, or whatever, that's just not the right thing to do.
So I'm just totally against that, so I take everybody, you know, come to me, I'm going to take you
off all your antioxidants, so let's testing you, that tests good for you, but it's a few people
that do, so I don't think you should be a mitocuteryl and it's a subtle, but that's my opinion.